blakely has the most difficult job at
cincinnati zoo he has to play with
babies all the time
he's never shown any aggression or
snapped if he gets upset kind of like
any mom would he just leaves the room
you are so confused
my name is don strasser and we're at the
cincinnati zoo and botanical gardens
blakely is a five-year-old australian
shepherd we got him from a rescue and i
use him in a nursery as a nanny or a
companion dog this is about you and
you're taking a nap blakely's here for
the main purpose of teaching the babies
the correct animal cues as they grow up
so when they are introduced back to
their own kind they know what
appropriate behavior is he teaches them
how to play how to interact
i can tell him no don't bite me but
i'm not an animal and i don't give the
same cues that he can so we make a great
team
smile for the kids for the camera
camera
blakely has worked with cheetahs
ocelots a talking
battered foxes a warthog
wallabies
to name a few he's working with four
baby cheetahs right now
it's been a long seven weeks for him
with these little cheetah cubs and he's
i think tired because he's on alert for
24 hours a day if they start making too
much noise he'll come and get us like
something's not right something's not
right
he's kind of like a second set of eyes
for us too a lot of times they still
recognize each other like dale the talk
and he raised when they see each other
he'll they'll still run up up front and
grunt at him and he'll kind of jump up
on the wall and it's kind of like hey
how you doing
he's beautiful thank you
yeah well i i like to think i have an
office but i'm pretty sure it's his
at new york's american museum of natural
history we are past the roosevelt atrium
through the frick building and tucked
away behind drawers of bones dr jack
sang is hard at work he's a dog guy i
have worked on dog evolution dog fossil
for about 10 years
jack's the man when it comes to dog
evolution and he says dogs might have a
shot at outliving us all
humans have been evolving for roughly 3
million years but dogs have been around
way longer and that history goes all the
way back 40 million years
it hasn't been easy they've dealt with
warming cooling the ice age
to determine how dogs are going to fare
as the world changes you have to start
in the past because dogs are
evolutionary marvels
the first dogs weren't really dogs as we
know them today they were tree dwellers
and really small
they changed to survive their legs
lengthened so they could run longer
distances and they grew a lot
during the ice age the big wolves
weighed around 140 pounds
but it's their teeth that are really the
key to their survival
their teeth were getting stronger to
deal with the larger bones and the grit
that they might get in their mouth when
they're hunting
what he's saying is that it's biological
that dogs are eating machines
think of their teeth as a basic
blueprint that goes back 40 million
years and can be adapted to any kind of
environmental change
the teeth in the back crush bone those
teeth in the middle are for cutting and
the front teeth are for puncturing
what's more dog's teeth have reinforced
surfaces
that means their teeth will stay intact
whether they're eating large bones or
chewing up carcasses
it also means dogs don't really need us
they'll be able to survive even if we're
no longer around to feed them because
they can eat pretty much anything that
comes their way
if we do go and they're left i'm sure
they'll adapt to whatever environment
that comes their way
pets
love us unconditionally and they don't
judge us
being up here and having a place for the
dogs makes all the difference in the
world
i know you're happy
i'm glad
dog mountain in the dog chapel is an
open dog park where dogs can really
connect with nature and enjoy spending
time outdoors with their with their
owners and having a place like the dog
chapel really helps people say goodbye
or also just leave a little message
about how much they loved them
it was basically started by artist
stephen hunick
he said the worst thing he'd ever heard
is it's just a dog
that's why stephen built the dog chapel
to memorialize these wonderful creatures
that have touched our lives so much
we've got people that pilgrimage from
every state and every continent
just to bask in the walls of the chapel
and leave a little message behind
they take comfort in knowing that those
pictures and those messages will be here
for years to come
i think dogs can bring out the best of
us and yeah it's it's horrific to say
goodbye but that's true of so many
losses in our lives
there are some places of reverence up
here i think for a lot of people however
they choose to recognize that
dogs are really special and it's one of
a kind place that we have here that
allows dogs to really shine and be
cherished as the wonderful little
creatures that they are
to be happy and healthy
they need to be able to run
and
maybe just maybe this is
my role in this world is to provide that
for them
my name is tc waite and i'm a dog musher
rescuing these dogs and giving them a
home is really important
we have right now 23 sled dogs on the
property
we kind of have this
motley crew of
scratch and dent sort of dogs that have
come to us from a variety of different
places
we have a group that have been rescued
we've got some from shelter we've got
some retired racing sled dogs that are
living out their golden years with us
in my mind it's a second chance for
these dogs
are you ready to hurt us
yeah
huskies love to pull a sled
it keeps them active it keeps their mind
focused this is what they were bred to
do over
generations even though they're older or
maybe they can't keep up with a race
team they still love to do it you don't
have to be the prima ballerina in order
to enjoy dance
the way that we make this work is we go
back and forth between colorado and
alaska so in the summer times we're down
south in colorado and hold down jobs and
save all that we can during the summer
so that we can put it away towards
towards the winter we manage to
transport
21 to 22 dogs over 3 000 miles each way
twice a year
i've got friends and family they might
not understand our crazy little life but
they they understand that we're doing
good things for these dogs
there is nothing like
experiencing a dog team in action
you're
literally dropped into this snow globe
of
wilderness that you can explore
and
you get to do it with your best friends
it just makes my heart sing
it's great life
i won't change it for anything
i was a model
i was always in heels and pumps and
platform shoes and i worried about my
weight
there just came a time i just said
enough you know i'm not happy anymore
i came to alaska with one dog and about
500 in my pocket because i wanted to be
a sled dog musher
i knew that life in alaska was for me
basically the moment i stepped off the
airplane
i got here and the mountains just blew
me away
it's like how some people feel when they
see the ocean
i personally don't feel isolated at all
in alaska because i'm surrounded by a
lot of dogs and a lot of family
racing is fun and i enjoy that but
there's a great need for rescue in
alaska
we take dogs that are rejected from
other teams and other kennels
they all have their own unique stories
and this is to me the most rewarding
work we can do
i'm training for the iditarod 2016.
the iditarod is the world's longest and
probably most well-known sled dog race
it's a thousand miles it starts in the
anchorage and goes to gnome and it
covers some amazing country and it goes
up on the coast off of the bering sea
to be on the sled with the dogs feels
amazing
you're part of this wild world where
there's caribou and there's moose and
you've got the sunrise you get the
sunset you get the stars over you get
the moon over you
and it's a great feeling to be a part of
that
you